epinephrine or more commonly known as
adrenaline is a hormone associated with
the fight-or-flight response upon
release it sends every organ and muscle
involved in motor movement and
metabolism into a peak physical response
in an adrenaline release people have
been known to withstand injuries that
would stop most people and exceed
strength levels of a physically fit
human let's see why all this happens on
a biochemical level but first has this
ever happened to you excuse me
we
do you know where the louvre is
francais whatever you do don't say you
speak french
uh we we no and i have no idea what he's
saying just nod your head and smile
awkwardly i really wish i paid attention
in 6th grade french thankfully through
babel this doesn't have to happen to you
babel is the number one language
learning app in the world it's different
from your typical language app they
don't rely on an ai to make hand
exercises their lessons are written by
real language instructors who go the
extra mile to craft practical
conversations using culture slang and
traditions to develop real world
interactions i live in upstate new york
not too far from montreal so when i
visit i use babble to brush up on my
french save
got it awesome sessions are in short
10-minute interactions so you can
practice whenever you have a few minutes
throughout the day if you click the link
in the description below you can get
sixty-five 65 off your babble
subscription and a 20-day money-back
guarantee check out babel today
adrenaline is produced in the medulla
located at the center of your adrenal
glands which sit on top of your kidneys
adrenaline is released when the central
nervous system goes into threat response
mode your central nervous system that is
your brain and spinal cord operates in
two different states the parasympathetic
state and the sympathetic state the
parasympathetic state controls your
normal daily functions or simply rest
and digest like keeping your heart
beating respiration going digestion the
boring day-to-day stuff right now
watching this video your nervous system
is in the parasympathetic state unless
you perceive this video as a threat
which is kinda weird is it my voice in
contrast the sympathetic nervous system
controls your fight-or-flight response
which initiates release of adrenaline
rerouting all resources to the heart
brain and muscles sending your body from
this the else can finish it off do the
rest of it to this
the whole process starts in the brain
specifically in the amygdala and the
hypothalamus the amygdala controls
responses to fear distress and anger
whereas the hypothalamus controls your
body's homeostasis like body temperature
breathing heart rate the boring stuff
the amygdala and hypothalamus respond to
threats before you're able to process it
this is why you instinctively jump out
of the way of a moving car there's no
thought to it you just do it when the
amygdala perceives a threat it alerts
the hypothalamus which then signals the
sympathetic nervous system to turn on
the first thing that happens is not
release of adrenaline instead the
hypothalamus increases your breathing
which then signals your heart rate to
increase this is to get your circulation
moving very fast so when adrenaline is
released it gets delivered much faster
if adrenaline was released before the
heart rate increased there would be a
delay between its release and its effect
on your organs and it would just be
floating in your bloodstream like hey
you know there is a bear coming uh you
better run once heart rate is up the
sympathetic nervous system via splanchik
nerves stimulates the adrenal gland to
release about 500 nanograms or less than
half a milligram of adrenaline into the
blood the adrenal gland receives blood
from three different arteries allowing
it to distribute adrenaline quickly and
efficiently this is where things get
wild once in the blood adrenaline binds
to two types of receptors called alpha
and beta-angionerdric receptors nearly
every cell type in your body has these
receptors which is why adrenaline
affects the entire body when adrenaline
binds to these receptors it initiates an
emergency response in different cell
types thereby changing the function of
the organs that the cells make up both
the alpha and beta receptors have
different effects on organs when
adrenaline binds to them for example
when adrenaline binds to the alpha
adrenergic receptors on blood vessel
cells and muscle cells blood flow and
metabolism change blood vessels in the
peripheral circulation will constrict
which reduces blood flow to areas that
do not contribute to the fight or flight
response such as smooth muscle in your
intestines instead blood is diverted to
the brain heart and muscles insulin is
halted from being released in the
pancreas to keep your blood sugar levels
elevated from muscles to use for energy
production glycogenolysis which is the
conversion of glycogen stores into
glucose is also ramped up in the liver
and muscles to further convert
carbohydrate stores into energy
basically when adrenaline binds to alpha
receptors the brain liver heart and
muscles get all the blood and fuel sent
to them when adrenaline binds to beta
receptors it causes maximum blood flow
and maximum cardiac output for blood
flow blood vessels in the heart muscles
brain and lungs dilate maximizing their
blood and oxygen intake in cardiac
output the heart is signaled to beat
faster and contract harder which is why
your chest is pounding during an
adrenaline rush additional effects
adrenaline has on the body are
thickening of saliva pupil dilation
reduce auditory senses tunnel vision and
enhanced long-term memory people have
stated under an adrenaline rush that
time slowed down and a situation that
was just a few minutes felt like a whole
hour this is because your brain is
processing so much information per
second that it feels like time is
actually slower the analogy is similar
to looking out the window of a
slow-moving car versus a fast-moving car
when the car is moving slower you're
able to recognize more detail whereas in
a fast-moving car you're able to
recognize less information your brain on
adrenaline is traveling in a fast-moving
car but recognizing details at the
efficiency of a slow-moving car
adrenaline is the closest thing humans
have to a superpower speaking of super
powers under high adrenaline response
humans have been documented to lift
weights well above normal human
standards known as hysterical strength
this isn't surprising though as the
muscles are getting nearly all the blood
glucose and oxygen they can handle for
example in 2012 in glen allen virginia
22 year old lauren kornecki lifted her
father's bmw when it fell off the jack
stands pinning him under it in 2019 16
year old football player zachary clark
lifted a 3 000 pound car off his
neighbor when it fell off the jack
stands while doing work on the car
however adrenaline is not only used
during the fight-or-flight response
during late stages of intense exercise
adrenaline has been found in large
amounts in the blood this is likely an
evolutionary mechanism as a last-ditch
effort to help us flee from predators
when nearing physical exhaustion
despite adrenaline being a useful
defense mechanism from evolution it does
have some serious negative effects on
our body in modern society recall that
one of the effects of adrenaline is
enhanced long-term memory specifically
from the hippocampus this is a feature
that likely helped us to recognize
patterns of what tried to kill us and
hold on to that memory then when a
stimulus occurs that's similar to the
past experience our memory goes into
overdrive and lets us know that it's
happening again patterns that could jog
our memory could be colors shapes smells
and sounds this was really great as
cavemen when we were being chased by
predators now fast forward 2 million
years in the future and this memory
recall from an adrenaline rush becomes
post-traumatic stress disorder or ptsd
it's one thing to have ptsd in the wild
to keep you alive but now we live in
safe predictable environments and yet
can be triggered by a sound or smell
that puts us into an aggressive survival
mode which is less likely to be needed a
study was done to observe whether
adrenaline had positive negative or
neutral effects on people an experiment
was performed where subjects were
injected with adrenaline and then shown
scenes from films that induced fear
anger and humor and then compared
results to a group that was not given
adrenaline results reveal that the group
that was given adrenaline showed strong
negative emotions compared to the
non-adrenaline group regardless of the
stimuli whether it induced fear anger or
humor overall adrenaline is still a
beneficial adaptation that can help us
to fight or flee from danger
use immense strength or remember
dangerous encounters